[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and job
or as I first think of it Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast about death
where my brother John and I will answer
your questions will give you dubious
advice and will bring you all the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
the AFC Wimbledon news this week it is a
big big big big AFC Wimbledon maybe the
biggest one ever I you're just gonna
have to wait though all of you people
listening to the end of the podcast
because we can't tell you we have to do
all the questions stuff which I know is
the boring stuff that nobody's here for
they're really all just here for the AFC
Wimbledon news John I actually think
that this week they will be pretty
pleased and surprised and excited about
the AFC women's news it's pretty it's
pretty freakin cool but uh but but first
I have to ask you John how are you doing
I'm doing great
entirely because of the AFC Wimbledon
news that for some reason I'm not
allowed to talk about until the end of
the podcast I have thought about nothing
else all day how are you I believe you
I'm good I'm in Los Angeles it's
actually a little chilly but I I do like
it chilly so I'm not complaining and
I've gotten to see so many cool people
in the last two weeks I'm just so
pleased to be a part of of this this
community of creators and and I just
think it's so fascinating and I love
talking to them and I'm just such a
fanboy and it's such it's so cool to be
both a fanboy and the creator and for
people to like to want to talk to me
even though I'm yeah I'm mostly just
just am a fan and they're like well
let's have conversation about it'll be
useful to both of us and I'm like yes
sure I'm sure it will but really I just
want to talk about how great you are and
I like how I like the content you make
so it's been really fun and I I'm gonna
make at least two videos out of the
stuff that I've collected while I'm here
and I'm excited for both of something
well I am thrilled for the fact that
you're in Los Angeles on my behalf so
that I don't have to be there yeah I
mean there are lots of bad parts about
it mostly the getting from one place to
another you know I thought that it was
that the traffic in LA was bad but it's
really just that it's gigantic
the
the traffic can actually be quite good
but it still takes a like 45 minutes to
get somewhere because it's just a very
big place also the traffic is terrible
would you like a short poem for the day
yeah tell me all about it I thought I
would read you another haiku by Richard
Wright actually I like the last Richard
Wright haiku so much and I like this one
so much written right at the end of his
life when he was living in exile in
Paris he wrote burning out its time and
timing its own burning one lonely candle
oh yes the beautiful little hell yeah I
like at the end of life that was great
high quality I know he's right that
Richard Wright you know he could he
could do a lot of different things great
nonfiction writer great novelist and
turns out a pretty darn good haiku
writer I know nothing about this person
what do you mean you don't know anything
about Richard Wright of course you know
something about Richard Wright what do I
know about him
I mean I'm googling right airlie certain
that you read a Richard Wright novel in
high school like native son or his
memoir black boy I'm pretty positive
that every American high school student
has to read at least one Richard Wright
book well I will say that despite what I
may have been required to read in high
school I didn't read all those books
alright well let's just answer some
questions from our listeners before I
start getting mad at you for all the
things that you haven't read alright we
got a lot of good questions here John do
you want to start with a fun one or a
serious one phone Oh John this may be my
favorite dear Hank and John question of
all time it's from Sam who asks dear
Hank and John I work at Subway and
sometimes I worry about the health of my
customers especially children eius wage
this by giving customers light
mayonnaise when they don't specify what
kind of mayonnaise they want or giving
them far more spinach than lettuce when
they ask for both is it wrong of me to
sneak these healthier options into
customers sandwiches if they don't know
about it wow that's a great question I
do not know how to feel about you Sam
you're a little you're a little Maya a
little Sneaky Subway sandwich artist hey
as you know my wife is also a former
subway employee we aren't
I was never a subway employee I think
that you're you're mixing it up I'm a
frequent subway customer okay okay it's
a common mistake but I will also say
John and I I am a frequent subway
customer and in fact the the guy who
even who works at my subway he may yeah
I'm pretty sure he's a fan so he may be
listening right now hello Ethan if
you're out there I have to say that a
well-made Subway sandwich is so much
better than a poorly made Subway
sandwich that first off I value Sam's
seriousness about his work I also value
the fact that he uses more spinach than
lettuce even though spinach is more
expensive I don't know if his manager
has told him that but the manager at my
Subway definitely has and I don't think
if if there are no specific requests for
kind of mayonnaise I think it's fine to
use light mayonnaise if you think that's
the better mayonnaise for the sandwich I
don't know that I and I think it's fine
to use more spinach if you think that's
better for the sandwich I don't think
that Sam that it is your place to make
other people's health
yes decision I think that I think that
the light mayonnaise at Subway and the
mayonnaise mayonnaise at Subway are not
even close to the same thing if I ask
for mayonnaise I know what I'm asking
for and it is not the light mayonnaise
which is a very different thing I'm
looking up it's like it's like it's like
I took its if I it's like if I asked for
mayonnaise and they gave me ketchup they
are that really to me they are they're
deeply or like ranch dressing instead of
instead of mayonnaise it's just no
k-lite mayonnaise has 50 calories and 5
grams of fat mayonnaise regular
mayonnaise has oh my a hundred ten
calories and 12 grams of fat so it
really isn't the same thing no it is not
and and also it is a fairly significant
contribution to the health of your
customer but and maybe it's okay to like
you can sort of feign the fact that you
made a mistake if they come back and
they're like what did you do and then
you have to throw the sandwich away and
but if it's a chilled if it's a child
especially the problem
we aren't going to be able to tell
because children have just notoriously
know no connection with reality I do not
understand them at all but I I do think
that it is somewhat problematic to be
sort of yeah making the health choices
of other people for them and I think
that right I mean to use an extreme
example like without being their doctor
you for instance don't know if maybe
they've been told that they need to get
much much more fat into their diet for
some reason so yeah I think that
obviously that's unlikely but it's not
impossible so I don't think it's your
place to make other people's health
decisions or in fact to judge their to
judge the food that they're eating right
right no yeah and I I do like that's
sort of my bigger problem with this is
like like the the way that we judge
other people for the way that they eat
is I think problematic but if somebody
asks for spinach and you give them more
they can always take it off but I don't
think many people wouldn't complain
about having more spinach from their
Subway sandwich in fact usually I am I'm
wondering why I got so little so um yeah
I always have to guiltily ask for more
I've actually started to offer an extra
quarter in exchange for a proper amount
of spinach I think our next question
comes from Jeanine who asks dear John
and Hank despite my university having a
strict honor code a lot of students
cheat on homework and tests on the one
hand I know these students are missing
out on getting the most of their
education but on the other hand they're
cheating hurts me because class grades
are often curved depending on class
averages especially if I won't be able
to directly apply what I'm learning
outside of an academic setting how could
I come to terms with people around me
getting higher grades than I do
when they aren't grappling with the
material do they deserve these high
grades if they can successfully cheat
and not get caught am I just a sucker
for not figuring out how to play the
system mmm so let me submit that you are
asking many different questions that
have different answers are you a sucker
for not figuring out how to play the
system no they are suckers for spend
money on a college education that is not
educating them yes do they deserve these
high grades if they can successfully
cheat of course they don't deserve the
high grades how can I come to terms with
people around me getting higher grades
than I do when they aren't grappling
with the material I would answer that
question by saying that grades don't
actually matter very much and grappling
with the material matters a lot so yeah
to me that's how you come to terms with
it yeah I mean I don't think that it's
your moral obligation to turn those
people in no I agree with that but I
also think that like we have this
structure in our education system that
makes us think that the grade is the
most important thing and in a lot of
ways it is but but mostly on the way to
university does it matter
mostly it's a like it's it's like
judging you to make sure that you are
placed into into university and can get
scholarships if you need them but once
once you're there this is this is not
about the letter that you end up with at
the end of the semester this is about
know learning and being being a better
person and in gaining that knowledge and
insight and I think that it's it's more
important that you struggle and that you
you know you even maybe talk to your
professor about like the success in
perils of your struggle and like and and
you know depending on what you're
studying of course this is all very
different stuff but the like the the the
knowledge of and the connection between
you know you and your professors is
going to be you know just by the virtue
of like you progressing and struggling
is going to be you know more significant
than your peers who are just coasting
and you know using whatever tools they
can to get that letter bigger yeah yeah
the letter is I mean as someone who
hires a lot I just don't buy the
argument that the letter is very
important I just don't think GPA isn't
very important I think where you go to
college is like slightly important I
think what you study is slightly
important but I think in the end it's
about
skill sets and you know and being able
to contextualize yourself and understand
social cues and work in teams and lots
of things that frankly college isn't
very focused on in most classes I have
never looked at a GPA while hiring ever
ever ever I have no idea if any of these
people even graduated from college to be
honestly yeah I was recently surprised
to find that one of one of the may be
the highest person at our company who
isn't me and John
I don't believe graduated from college
and one of the highest people didn't
graduate from high school right I mean I
think that there is kind of an
equivalent experience category yeah when
it comes to applying for jobs that said
I still think that it's best to go to
college and complete it in in the vast
majority of cases yeah absolutely and
the statistics are with me although less
and less each year as college becomes
less and less reasonable but but yeah in
terms of its cost you mean by reasonable
less and less reasonable by cost yes I
think that it is remains reasonable in
terms of valuing reason all right we
have another question this is from
Katherine she writes dear John and Hank
in 2009 John made a video about the
stimulus plan that was going to be
signed into action by the President on
February 16th of that same year
I was wondering how has this affected us
has it worked has it hurt or helped us
what has happened since then it's a
great shot I don't know I I do you and
you you know you tell me John you tell
me okay so it is very hard to find
economists who do not acknowledge that
the stimulus plan which was called the
American Recovery and Reinvestment Act
of 2009 was a success in the sense that
it probably lowered the basement of the
recession in fact the stimulus plan has
been used in lots of conversations among
economists since then as evidence for
the Keynesian economic
in which during recessions governments
offset decreases in private spending by
increasing public spending lots of
economists have been like look it worked
it pretty clearly worked this is as
close as we can get to a real-world
example of the Keynesian economic model
working now of course the other side of
the Keynesian economic model that
governments spend less during periods of
growth is the part that nobody wants to
embrace right right because mm-hmm
that's the part where you have to be
like Oh things are going well we're
going to spend less money and just keep
it minoo in a lockbox somewhere so for
when things aren't going well that's a
little bit of an actually unfair
oversimplification of Keynesian economic
theory and all surprises that I am NOT
an economist I'm just I was however the
third-best C student in economics when I
was in 11th grade at the Alabama State
Academic Decathlon
did the stimulus work yes obviously it
did not immediately end the recession
but it probably made the recession suck
less and there's a chance that if it
hadn't been for the stimulus the
recession would have sucked so much
worse that it would have led to a
deflationary spiral which would have led
to a big Great Depression like thing but
it speaks to our short political and
economic memory that almost no one ever
talks about the 2009 stimulus anymore
and when we do talk about it we talk
about it as a thing that made a small
impact because it was ultimately a
pretty small impact one way or the other
so if the stimulus had failed it would
have failed in a minor way and that the
stimulus and that in at least I think
the stimulus succeeded but it succeeded
in a minor way and in general that's the
case for almost all of these like
legislative initiatives that we fight
and die over and say are going to save
or ruin a
America right when we look back at them
eight or nine years later we think well
that was a modest success or that was a
modest failure like we look back at the
Bush Medicare prescription drug plan and
say well that was a modest failure and
we look back at Obamacare and say either
I mean I think either that's a modest
success or that's a modest failure I
mean the truth is not that many people
are enrolled on the exchange it hasn't
changed things that much about any here
so I just think a lot of times the stuff
we fight over eyes the wrong like it's
stuff that's not gonna be that important
in the future but I'm mostly here in
these conversations as Obamacare was a
massive failure it's hard to say that
Obamacare is a massive failure when no I
completely agree with you
I completely agree but that is it is you
know in terms of what we want to talk
about it it I think it often has more to
do with with how we want to how we how
the people in the news media want to
frame the issue because they want to
frame the issue in a way that is good
for the politics that they ascribe to I
yeah I I think I think that we shouldn't
get too caught up in this John but I I
do like your answer all right well then
let's just move on all right I got a
question from Renee who asks dear Hank
and John now that we have established
some armrest etiquette I feel it's not
time to decide another one
drive-throughs what are your thoughts on
a threshold to decide whether a person
needs to order inside or use the
convenience of the drive-through no more
than three complicated Starbucks drinks
no minivans ordering for the family of
six should they be treated like ten
items or less lanes at the grocery store
oh come on
Renee you can't you can't you you can't
tell people how they're gonna use the
drive-thru anybody can use the
drive-thru if they want to if they don't
want to pull eight thousand kids out of
their car seats and put them back in
that's fine good you if you want
convenience can get out of your car and
go inside and have the shorter line and
I always feel like the drive-through
with is the short is the long option the
director who's always takes longer
because it's people who don't want to
get out of their cars I'm gonna go
inside and talk to a person because I
like them and I have strong opinions
apparently on this I actually don't know
which is longer but I do know
that if you have 17 kids you should be
allowed to use the drive-through because
anyone who's ever put one child in a car
seat knows that the thought of taking
that child out of the car seat for five
minutes to get food and then putting
that child back in the car seat is so
overwhelming that I'll sit in a
drive-through line for three hours the
other day I was driving past an in and
out and I was like I should get in and
out I'm in LA and and that line was that
long I was like I'm gonna go to
McDonald's there's no line at all I made
sure to go to in-n-out burger on my way
out of Los Angeles it's always my way of
saying goodbye to Los Angeles so I have
a nice memory I still haven't been to
in-n-out this trip I need to figure out
how to do that you should do it today
Catherine's sitting right next to me
she's looking at me with these eyes and
she's she's holding her hand to her
mouth and making making mouth motions
and now the whole hamburgers in there
the mind hamburger is inside of my life
I think I think we've settled this
question very quickly and efficiently
John great let's go to the next one
anonymous writes Dear John and Hank
recently my partner of half a decade
broke up with me out of the blue let's
just start by saying that you're saying
half a decade as a way of trying to like
make it longer which I'm gonna say more
about in a second he has been my best
friend for the many years we were a
couple we lived together and talked all
day now he has moved out and we have no
contact we've broken up and gotten back
together before in the past but I think
this time is different my friends all
say that space and no contact now is the
best thing in order to heal and to have
a chance at friendship later but
actually taking this advice feels like
the worst thing in the world what should
I do
I actually think that you should
probably take your friend's advice
although I am very sympathetic to the
fact that it is it truly probably does
feel like the worst thing in the world
there's an element of catastrophizing
that accompanies any major trauma or
major loss like losing a relationship
like this because the people around you
don't understand what a big deal it is
especially if you weren't married or if
you didn't have you know like it's
because it's not legally complicated
they think that it it's not emotionally
complicated and that you sort of just
need to kind of get over it but of
course that's very hard to do
practically / impossible I mean it hurts
because it mattered it hurts because it
was important and because there's a real
profound loss there but not
acknowledging the loss is not a way
forward you have to let yourself grieve
you have to let yourself be inside of
that that loss and you have to know that
it's okay not judge yourself for being
sad or angry or whatever you feel and
because only through that process of
grief are you going to get on the other
side when it is no longer the worst
thing in the world so I really think
that at least in my experience space and
no contact is the way to sort of rebuild
your life and go out with your friends
you know have as much of a social life
as you can handle and you will find
yourself slowly over the course of time
rebuilding a life that doesn't include
that person and eventually you will
probably if you're anything like me look
back on it and be like huh sure I'm glad
that happened now that's no comfort now
but I do think that that sometimes it
takes years but you look back on on your
life and you feel grateful for the way
things happened I don't know maybe that
so maybe that's hope too much hope just
give you the little bit of hope that
going out and hanging out with your
friends is a good thing to do yeah
yeah I agree I uh that's real rough it's
real rough I have another hard question
John do you want another one
greatly oh let's keep going this one's
from Gaby who asks dear Hank and John I
received a sexual invitation from a 60
year old former teacher awhile ago I am
17 I was going with him and I know him
to be a very good man otherwise but this
thing made me so angry I was angry that
he felt attracted to me I was angry that
he expressed those feelings to me why am
I so angry
well Gaby I think that your anger is
justified for a lot of different reasons
I think this is all
up with how how you imagine this man is
like a mentor and a friend but you know
obviously more of a you know an
authority and a leadership figure rather
than a peer and and you had an image of
this guy's a good person in your mind
and he broke it and he did that with he
must have done it with the knowledge
that it that that was the likely outcome
and I just can't I can't imagine that in
another way
ya know I mean I think you know you're
angry because you've been been hurt and
betrayed yeah in important ways your
trust yeah I was thinking like crazy
like your friendship has been betrayed
and you know you've been sexualized and
and romanticized in ways that that are
really abusive to you ultimately and and
it's not it's not fair it's not right
and it's okay to be angry I think that I
think sometimes we feel guilty about
about being angry and that that's just
like worsens the spiral of it so maybe
there's some comfort in knowing that
it's okay to be angry that in fact like
I think anger is probably the
appropriate emotional reaction there and
and then just to create the distance
that you need to to be well but it's
it's a huge betrayal and a big loss yeah
and and likely the cause of that is he's
like some some internal problems that he
has and it is completely possible to you
know be a good guy otherwise and have
also you know real issues that are very
you know very problematic and and that
he you know at this point probably will
never be able to deal with fully and
that's you know like it's in like yeah I
mean you this person intentionally
sacrificed a good a good relationship
for you know in his own weakness and and
it's very difficult to see that that
weakness and someone who is you know
much more powerful much older
and and you know and so the the result
is just sort of like deep like how could
this have happened kind of feeling and
and also like often times and I don't
know this doesn't seem like it's the
case in your situation but it it could
be that somehow you are responsible for
that but you are not yeah yeah that's
really important to emphasize and also
that like there is no such thing at
least in my opinion I feels pretty
strongly about this as a healthy
romantic relationship between a 17 year
old and a 60 year old because the power
dynamic can never be an equal especially
if that person was a former teacher like
they're in every way this is clearly a
the wrong yeah thing to have happen yeah
yeah I'm just really sorry but I think I
think you've handled it well all right
let's move on to another question and
just try to see if we can continue this
hilarious comedy podcast Dear John and
Hank um this might be the least funny
episode of our comedy podcast ever which
is really saying something not least
because we haven't really talked about
death yet
let's try and work it out well I will
try to work death into into this
question actually because I think I
think it's almost impossible to be
honest with you I think it's almost
impossible to answer this question
without talking about death so that
might be why it's an appealing question
to me okay okay you ready yeah this
question comes from Maya who asks dear
John and Hank I recently took a shower
with another person for the first time
and I very much enjoyed the experience
and everything turned out fine even
though this was a rather spontaneous
event I did find some time to worry
about it which left me wondering why do
farts smell so much worse in the shower
with love Maya Maya even heroically
included her last name but I'm not going
to read it in case her parents was into
this podcast well Maya I'm glad that you
asked this question about why farts
smell worse in the shower especially
when you're in the shower with someone
else the answer is that there are
trillions of bacteria inside of your
body and they are dying and eating and
as they die and eat they make sense
and that scent comes out well okay but
that's not the question and in fact John
I think you actually do know the answer
to this question because you wrote about
it and I believe an abundance of
katherines I mean I wrote that book like
ten years ago I have no memory of it is
is that is that the I apologize for
having done this to you right now but
that's the one with Collin who is who's
the the child product yes that's the one
about the child prodigy okay well he
said do you remember I do remember its
basic subject matter okay and there's a
there's a scene in that book where they
where they talk about how when you
shower turns on that shower curtain gets
sucked toward you but that seems like
the wrong thing right it seems like the
shower should turn on and it should push
the air out and the shower curtain
shouldn't try and touch you with it's
cold sign eNOS right you remember this
part of the book I do so I what happens
is and Collin knows the answer to this
it's Quinn
Colin Colin that right Colin okay good
I've got I remembered his name there's
it creates an air current inside of the
shower that's kind of like this like
weird sort of heat and and humidity
tornado that is happening around you and
and that brings air into the shower and
in toward the middle of the shower in
particular and what's happening is all
of the air that's in the shower is sort
of like being rushed around your face
and it's being taken from all around you
and sort of brought up and out in you
know in this convection current in your
shower and and what's happening is your
fart smell is just being brought much
more quickly up to your nose without
being dispersed very much you're also of
course in an enclosed container when
you're in a shower which it could have
been it could have been the partner's
fart smell we don't know that wasn't
where I don't know that somebody's fart
smell the point is somebody's you know
the sort of the remnants of the the dead
and dying and eating bacteria that has
colonized your body as being forced into
your face yeah right well I think my
read of this question was that Maya is
worrying about a future potential
problem rather than an actual occurrence
in the first lovely experience of
partner showering
maybe I don't know I assume it like it
was like a sweet funny thing that
happened and they were able to like
laugh it off because you know we're
having our first shower etc III either
way I do believe that that is I'm just
you know what I'm just happy that
somebody is in it apparently a happy
relationship or just real close friends
you know yeah yeah or right but that's
still a relationship whether it's
romantic or not is of less concern to me
than just it being like highly function
well John this podcast is brought to you
by non romantic partner shower farts
romantic shower farts a little
embarrassing but mostly just fun and of
course this podcast is brought to you by
the news from AFC Wimbledon the news
from AFC Wimbledon Honka I can't believe
that I still don't get to talk about it
yet and of course this podcast is
brought to you by all those suckers who
don't cheat in college what are they
thinking paying money learning come on
and finally this podcast is brought to
you by regular Subway mayonnaise regular
Subway mayonnaise containing more
calories and fat than bread like the
whole sandwich bread I just I hate
mayonnaise I there is no other than
pickles there is no sort of broadly
available American food I find more
reprehensible than American mayonnaise I
disagree it is the best it is the best
it is disgusting it it it always looks
to me like some kind of industrial
lubricant you know like it's used to
make ball bearings work properly
do you think it's its color it's a it's
sort of off-white yellowish color is a
is a problem for mayonnaise I think it's
a branding issue and if it were more
like ranch dressing which is sort of
white with fun speckles that would be
that would be better for mayonnaise but
in the end I think that man is it has a
rich history and a rich flavor and I'm a
hundred percent on the mayonnaise
boat emphasis on the rich for sure this
podcast is brought to you by the
mayonnaise boat it's a boat made of
mayonnaise this broadcast is also
brought to you by our supporters on
patreon if you want to go to patreon.com
slash dear Hank and John you can join
the community there whether or not you
give us money there there are stuff
there for you but also you can give us a
buck or something and to help us pay for
our intern in our editor and they would
appreciate it also we just got this
question from Josh who writes Dear John
and Hank is it possible to purchase a
dear Hank and John t-shirt heck yes it
is Josh at dftba.com you can get an oh
my god it's burning shirt which reminds
me oh my god it's burning
well done John well done we have another
question this one's from Ryan and Ryan
says dear Hank and John my name is Ryan
and I'm fortunate enough to live a
pretty comfortable lifestyle by the way
wait wait what what's his name by the
way my name is Ryan so is the 17th time
you said that his name is Ryan in the
course of 12 so I've recently started to
attend a new University and my new
friends who call me Ryan are not as
fortunate as me one of my friends told
me I don't know why I don't know why
that joke got me so much but it got me
so much oh my god one of my friends told
oka one of my friends said to me Ryan I
can't afford groceries this week I just
keep doing it it doesn't stop being
funny for me it's like a sine wave it's
like every time I think that I've heard
enough rides another one comes that I
just I've like literally in tears
so I Ryan offered to pay for her
groceries and she got mad at me who is
Ryan for suggesting that for suggesting
that and now won't even talk to Ryan
anymore
I've had other similar experiences when
trying to help my friends out am I wrong
for trying to help my friends out
financially I just want to help them
love Ryan who is Ryan Ryan
I like your podcast I'm sorry to laugh
at what is not not a funny funny but
it's also not like it's not the heaviest
one we've dealt with it's this episode
though so if we're gonna make a judge
what I would say here's what I would say
Ryan Ryan I think that you are trying to
be nice and helpful would you say John
would you would you say would you say
he's trying Katherine doesn't like this
she's negative face I would say I would
say Ryan that you are trying to be nice
and helpful but when lots and lots of
people tell you that you are not being
nice or helpful it is important to
listen to them right so if I am mately
isn't helpful to them to be constantly
reminded that at a moment's notice you
could help out with small problems they
may have like groceries because probably
the big financial problems that they
have while they wouldn't be big
financial problems for you are things
that you know you can't easily solve for
them like tens of thousands of dollars
of college debt or whatever so in my
experience you know if someone asks for
help that's one thing but I would wait
until they ask right I mean it it's so
hard to understand how weird money is in
our society and and yeah you know and
and what a gigantic divider it is among
us I would say to be conscious of your
friends economic positions and like
don't like if you if you know that your
friends are having a problem like paying
for groceries don't be like let's go out
to have drinks you know right find ways
to like host at your house or at you
like you can do nice things for these
people and and you can talk to them and
like and help them with with their
issues but and and also like don't loan
them money to be clear giving money to a
friend is always better than loaning
money to a friend because then you're
setting yourself up for a really weird
power dynamic if you're sort of always
expecting the money to come back to you
but yeah but you know I you know if a
friend is in a seriously bad situation
and and and they need help it is willing
is is worth maybe having a serious
conversation with them but this isn't a
little thing when you're just like start
to you know front your friends cash all
the time and and like you know
understanding the position that you are
in can be very confusing to people who
have never been in your situation just
like just like you are going to not
fully understand what it's like to be in
their situation so I applaud you for
wanting to help out but it is surprising
how weird this all is and you have to be
careful because it's it's our weirdest
thing I think we are we are we are I
don't know I don't know if money is our
weirdest thing you know what I think is
our weirdest thing awareness thing at
any moment completely without cause or
explanation your entire existence can be
snuffed out oh good you're right I think
that is our weirdest thing John alright
Hank before we get to the news from AFC
Wimbledon and Mars but mostly from AFC
Wimbledon I am so excited we have one
update from Katy who writes dear John
and Hank i love the podcast been
listening since the very first one Thank
You Katy lots of people say that but
only you mean it I know several times
you've discussed the issue of the human
microbiome it is one of my passions and
how bacteria can outnumber our cells by
several times or at least or a
comparable number however Hank did bring
up that they are normally very small and
this didn't seem to sway John since he
still considers himself to be half
bacteria I don't consider myself to be
half bacteria I am factually half
bacteria so I posed this question to you
John do you consider a cupcake with one
sprinkle to be equal parts cupcake and
sprinkle do you consider a cupcake with
even a couple sprinkles to be eat to be
overwhelmingly sprinkle human and
bacterial cells are similar in sizes
relationally to a cupcake and a sprinkle
is it not that possible to see that you
are in fact not overwhelmingly bacteria
and plus they're only really isolated to
your mucous membranes and skin most of
your inside is sterile
most of my inside what are you saying
about some of my inside
Katie well a great deal of your inside
is covered in bacteria as previously
yeah I mean lots of my stomach has a
bacteria crawling all over it
the question would I consider a cupcake
with one sprinkle to be equal parts
cupcake and sprinkle the answer to that
is yes so oh I think without the context
of our current conversation maybe you
would have had a different take on that
but I understand you sticking to your
guns John because you're a stubborn dude
I am a man who passionately believes
that he is half bacteria and there is no
talking me out of it
all right John
let's let's do the news from our sake
what's the news from ours what's the
news from Earth what's the news from
ours okay well the news from our day it
could fast make it fast maybe yes we've
got a we've got a science spat going on
in the Mars community right now in Neil
deGrasse Tyson and Elon Musk are having
a bit of a tiff mostly it's Neil
deGrasse Tyson and Elon Musk ignoring it
but Neil thinks that it's a ludicrous
that SpaceX is going to lead the space
frontier he in fact calls it a delusion
and and says that it's just not going to
happen because the US government that or
governments have much more long-term
views of these things and can afford to
invest over decades to make one thing
happen whereas private sector is much
much worse that those kinds of things
people have different takes on this of
course and and in the Mars community it
has been quite a little bit of a fracas
I believe is a word that means what I
mean and you know on musk stake on the
other hand it's just to ignore the whole
thing and continue to just make billions
of dollars oh it's hard out there for
you on my side sometimes he has to mute
Neil deGrasse Tyson on Twitter all right
John I made it as quick as I good so
that you could get to the AFC Wimbledon
news which I agree is pretty cool this
week it was announced that the AFC
Wimbledon's story could do you want to
first - what do you want to first tell
us how they're doing in the table just
like just a quick over not good
yeah AFC Wimbledon have dropped to 10th
in league to having lost a critical game
against Hartlepool 1 nil and are now
unlikely to reach the playoffs but
there's 8 games to go and you know hope
is the thing with feathers etc for
instance if you told me three months ago
that I was going to get to announce this
news today I wouldn't have believed you
so who knows the future is unpredictable
that's what makes it so amazing and
terrible this week it was announced that
the AFC Wimbledon's story will be told
in movie form this is in a movie to be
made by Fox 2000 studios produced by
wick and Isaac at temple Hill and by
rosianna and me at we don't have a name
for our production company but so I mean
like I know you've told the story of a
buildin many times in fact it appears
sometimes to me that you tell it every
single time you do the news because you
got them you got to make it seem
interesting but you have not told it in
the true full exciting built into a
narrative movie way I love I love sports
movies I don't like sports but I love
sports movies they just get me so
excited I always cry I yeah oh you're
gonna cry you're gonna cry when Danny
said well goes up to take that critical
penalty don't don't spoil it for me I
mean I am so excited about this this is
something that I've wanted to do of
course for ever since I got a production
deal with Fox and so I pitched the idea
to them I told them the AFC Wimbledon's
story you know just a small group of
really middle-aged people who had this
community institution that they loved
taken away from them and responded to
that not with hopelessness or despair
but with a strange and beautiful
commitment to restart it even if that
meant being in the ninth tier of English
football even if that meant you know
sitting on hay bales to watch games and
even if it meant having public you know
public tryouts in a park with no
uniforms or coaches or anything and then
they built it up in just 9 years all the
way to a football league team that's a
full-time professional club again it is
an amazing story about how people who
have a shared commitment in in what in
the time that we often associate with
midlife crises can instead like find
real meaning in their lives and in a
real community and kind of have it have
a new a new life in a way and AFC
Wimbledon got to have that new life and
so did the people who are at the center
of the story I'm so excited about this I
mean obviously there's a long long way
to go like they've got to hire a writer
and then find a screenplay that they
like and then find a director it's just
it's an incredibly long process things
often go go haywire but it's just so
exciting like I I just think I really
believe that the story of this this club
and the nine years that these guys spent
together building it I should say
guys and women spent together building
it is it amazing it's just an amazing
story and the more like you dig into the
details the more amazing it becomes and
I think you know that moment of getting
back into the Football League on a
penalty shootout with your 37 year old
captain who's never played a game of
professional football in his life
getting into the Football League in the
most dramatic way possible it's just a
great it's a great story I'm so excited
I've I can't I mean I am so freaking
excited for the for the prospect of an
AFC Wimbledon movie and I know it's a
little bit of a weird movie to be the
first one that we produce with our still
unnamed production company but it also
isn't because you know we like heartfelt
stories about real people and and this
is that so I think it's I think it's a I
think it's a great story I think it's
gonna make a great movie
I agree I'm so excited when you first
told me that you were thinking about you
know pitching this it seemed kind of
like a no-brainer to me because it's
it's
it's a great story and it's not a super
expensive one to tell it seems right up
Fox 2000s ally and and I you know like I
I mean I think that movie is going to be
do very well in South London yeah that's
gonna kill it in South London we're
gonna I mean I don't know if we'll be
the number one movie in America but
we'll definitely be the number one movie
in South London no I think you know the
other thing is that there's soccer
fandom is growing around the world but
especially in the US and and I think
learning about the history of one club
and how its looked how you know what
makes English football special which I
think AFC Wimbledon really captures what
makes English football so special and
makes the football pyramid so special I
think I think it'll excite American fans
too so and it's it's a heartwarming love
story really it's a love story about
these these people who loved their club
and loved each other but it's also
there's also you know some romantic love
stories in it so it's gonna be a it's
gonna have something for everybody not
something for everybody I'm very excited
do you have any idea like what the
timeline is on something like this I
have no idea what the timeline is
sometimes things happen in like two
years like it did with the Paper Towns
movie sometimes eleven years later like
with the Looking for Alaska movie it's
just two people who no longer speak to
each other so you never know how it's
gonna go alright God what did we learn
today
oh we learned that the AFC Wimbledon
movie is going to be the greatest thing
ever we learned that John Green has a
lot of thoughts on Keynesian economics
and how the viewpoints of it have been
reinforced by the economic stimulus plan
of 2009 that is I'm going to catch so
much flak from me from America is better
Recovery Act calm I am going to catch a
lot of flack for what I said about
Keynesian economics from the Austrians
out there not the people in it in
Austria the people who ascribe to the
Austrian school of that high
see I do not know I do not know what
else did we learn we learned that
there's something with Mars Neil
deGrasse Tyson going to Mars private
enterprise public funds AFC Wimbledon
movie I can't remember we learned
something about Mars yes
AFC Wimbledon movie something about Mars
and we learned you know and also and
also John a young man named Ryan taught
us that Ryan's name is Ryan the main
thing we learned is that is that Ryan's
name is Ryan hey can I tell you a quick
story that probably shouldn't be
included in the podcast yeah okay all
right
so for some reason there was a fact
recently in a Mental Floss video that
caused me to laugh so uproariously that
we had to briefly cancel issue and this
was the fact that in 2006 a New Zealand
man tried to sell Australia on eBay
[Laughter]
there are so many good facts on Mental
Floss I don't know why that's the one
it's just every detail of that fact
every detail of that fact is just so
beautiful I could just picture the New
Zealand demand like putting together all
of his pictures of Australia to use in
the eBay listing all right thank you for
the story John and thank you listener
for listening to our podcast if you were
watching it that's super-creepy land and
indianapolis at the same time and which
of these windows are you looking at
there's a lot of windows in this house
but thanks for listening and and thank
you John for joining me yes our podcast
is edited by nicholas jenkins our intern
is claudia morales we're very grateful
to rosianna halse rojas for her help in
gathering questions you can email us at
Hank and John at gmail.com or use the
hashtag dear Hank and John on Twitter or
snap us on snapchat I'm John Green snaps
or John Green snaps to
you read it Hank is Hank gr e Gunnar all
is responsible for our theme music John
is responsible for all of our thoughts
of morbidity and I am responsible for
basically attempting to carry this
entire thing on on the weight of all of
my own shoulders because everyone knows
that John's badass stuff and as they say
in our hometown don't forget I'm not
gonna give you a chance to respond